[Music]
hobok and like many other cities was
designed in terms of its streets and
roads for cars and we're trying to
change
that right across the Hudson River from
Manhattan the New Jersey City of Hoboken
has become an unexpected leader in
pedestrian safety just over a square
mile big the small Urban Enclave has
made it 6 years in counting without a
single traffic fatality making it an
outlier in the US where around 40,000
people die on roads each year part of
the transformation has been led by mayor
Ravi Bala who took office in
2018 I've been a resident of Hoboken for
about 23 years when I was younger I
noticed carrying a stroller uh with my
young daughter that I couldn't even pass
Main Street without pushing the stroller
ER into the middle of the road because
we simply had no pedestrian Crossing
signals so I didn't know when the light
would turn in order to cross safely uh
with my child I just thought intuitively
that that was a major problem so that's
when I started thinking about pedestrian
safety and how we can do better for
especially our most vulnerable
population so when I was elected we
started to hone in on developing a plan
which became the vision zero plan where
we seek to eliminate not only traffic
related deaths but also traffic related
injuries by 2030 cities around the world
have adopted similarly ambitious Vision
zero goals with mixed progress hoban's
neighbor New York City signed on to
Vision zero in 2014 but has seen more
than 200 people die in each of the
following 8 years Hoboken had a slightly
more targeted task between 2014 and 2018
the city saw nearly 4500 crashes on its
streets three of which caused deaths we
set up a vision zero task force to
engage stakeholders residents Engineers
Public Safety to all come together and
identify solutions that are Innovative
we kind of take a bird's eyye View and
see what lowcost high impact measures we
can Implement in order to make that part
of Hoboken a little bit safer hoboken's
redesign incorporates lots of examples
of something called daylighting which
creates more visibility at intersections
by keeping cars from parking too close
to the crosswalk so just with a bucket
of paint you can actually create a curb
extension you can create high visibility
crosswalks you can do a lowcost means by
putting in a bike rack or
ballards we've implemented a program
called 20 is plenty where the speed
limit Citywide is 20 mph we want to make
it easy and safe for you to walk or if
you want to ride a bike one of the means
we've implemented is partnering with
City bike and New York City and Jersey
City to implement a regional holistic
program to easily access a bicycle if
you don't own one and also joining that
with our program for bike Lanes so that
you can not only access a bike but you
can get from one place to another in a
safe manner Hoboken has taken a kitchen
sink approach pairing street redesigns
with speed limit changes and a spree of
bike friendly building in places like
resiliency Park you can see the changes
in
action so this intersection here kind of
exemplifies a lot of what we're trying
to do in terms of daylighting on both
sides of me you have rain Gardens which
serve a dual purpose of mitigating
flooding as well as providing pedestrian
safety we have Ada accessible high
visibility crosswalks endur blend in the
center to alert drivers that this is a
highly trafficked intersection as well
as other forms of daylighting such as
ballards on the left side which come at
a low cost but also a high impact in
terms of making sure cars are not parked
there and people can walk and bike
safely some roads are a little bit
narrow to allow both vehicular traffic
as well as biking so for those roads we
create shared
spaces not every Road in Hoboken feels
safe to share yet biking down hoboken's
busy commercial Main Street still means
weaving around double parked cars
because efforts to build a protected
bike lane have met resistance from local
businesses change is not easy we did
face a number of roadblocks Mr to speak
this is change that is not happening you
know within a day or a week uh it's very
incremental but at the same time it's
also very impactful it's very important
for public officials no matter who you
are and really the community to dream
big it's not expensive to create a bike
lane this is more a challenge of
changing the culture of Mobil ability in
Hoboken if we can change that culture
change that mentality behaviors of
residents that will Outlast any changes
in administrations um in governments
because progress it might be implemented
at the governmental level but it really
comes from from the
[Music]
residence